N
TELL YOU THAT MUCH.
PHIL MATTINGLY, APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, PHIL.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
AND NOW, WE TAKE YOU TO MEXICO.
GUNFIRE AND CLASHES ARE RESTING
IN A MAJOR CITY IN MEXICO AFTER
SECURITY FORCES LAUNCHED AN
OPERATION AGAINST A NOTORIOUS
DRUG LORD.
--
WAS ARRESTED.
HE IS THE SON OF THE INFAMOUS
DRUG CAN PAYING --
SO DANGEROUS IS THAT
AUTHORITIES ARE WARNING
RESIDENTS TO USE SHELTER AT
HOME.
THEY ARE REPORTING LOOTING AS
WELL AS BLOCKADES A VEHICLE AND
SEVERAL FIRES, AS YOU SEE
THERE.
LET'S GET MORE FROM RAFAEL LIVE
AT CNN CENTER.
RAFAEL, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
BRING US UP TO DATE WITH WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
HOW WORRIED IS THE SITUATION ON
THE GROUND.
>> IT'S A VERY CHAOTIC
SITUATION, ISA.
IT HAS BEEN FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL HOURS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
IN 2019.
IT'S HAPPENING ONCE AGAIN.
THE BIGGER ISSUE HERE IS
WHETHER THE MEXICAN SECURITY
FORCES HAVE THE CAPABILITY OF
CAPTURING A HIGH-PROFILE
SUSPECT WHILE KEEPING THE WHOLE
CITY SAFE.
THE SHORT ANSWER SEEMS TO BE NO
AT THIS POINT.
JUST A FEW MOMENTS AGO, MEXICAN
DEFENSE MINISTER --
CONFIRMED THE ARREST OF GUZMAN
AND ALSO SAID THAT 19 DIFFERENT
SITES ACROSS THE CITY HAD BEEN
TARGETED BY MEMBERS OF THE
CARTEL THAT WE FIRST HEARD
REPORTS FROM LOCAL MEDIA AND
NOW STATE AUTHORITIES HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT PART OF THE CITY
AND THE NORTHERN MEXICAN STATE
SEEM LIKE WAR ZONES.
THERE ARE CLASHES BETWEEN
SECURITY FORCES AND ALLEGED
MEMBERS OF THE CARTEL,
ACCORDING TO BOTH THE CITY
COUNCIL, THE STATE TOP SECURITY
OFFICIAL, AND FEDERAL OFFICIALS.
AS I SAID BEFORE, THE TOP
SECURITY OFFICIAL AT THE STATE
LEVEL SAID PEOPLE ARE HAVING
THEIR VEHICLES TAKEN FROM THEM.
THERE ARE BLOCKADES IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE CITY.
WE ARE ASKING CITIZENS TO NOT
GO OUT AND WE ARE TAKING
APPROPRIATE MEASURES.
ALL THIS CHAOS, HE SAYS, A
RESULT OF AN EARLY MORNING
OPERATION TO DETAIN WE OVIDIO
GUZMAN, THE SUN, AS YOU KNOW,
OF JOAQUIN WE EL CHAPO GUZMAN,
THE SENIOR LEADER CONVICTED IN
2019 OF TEN COUNTS, INCLUDING
ENGAGING IN A CONTINUING
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE, DRUG
TRAFFICKING AND FIREARMS.
CHARGES EL CHAPO WILL BE
SENTENCED TO LIFE IN PRISON
PLUS 30 YEARS HERE IN THE U.S..
SOME VIEWERS MAY REMEMBER HIS
SON WHEN OVIDIO GUZMAN BECAUSE
HE WAS DETAINED IN OCTOBER 2019
BY MEXICAN FEDERAL FORCES
DURING A RAID IN THE NORTHERN
CITY AFTER HE WAS DETAINED, THE
CARTEL UNLEASHED A HEAVILY
ARMED FORCE WHICH SEEMS TO HAVE
HAPPENED AGAIN TODAY.
A GUN BATTLE IN THE STREETS
ENSUED, PUTTING THE LIVES OF
COUNTLESS MILLIONS AT RISK.
IT QUICKLY BECAME PAINFULLY
OBVIOUS, HE SAID, THAT THE
CARTEL HAD OUTMANEUVERED AND
OVERPOWERED MEXICAN SECURITY
FORCES.
IN THE END, MEXICAN AUTHORITIES
DECIDED TO RELEASE GUZMAN TO WE
PREVENT FURTHER BLOODSHED.
TH